bezeichnenderweise kam das ganze thema
digitalisierung das angeblich so wichtig
ist im tv duell merkel schulz überhaupt
nicht vor ebenso wenig wie bildung
zukunftsthemen die gerade junge menschen
betreffen spielen keine rolle in diesem
wahlkampf
ich frage mal den heute show
alterspräsidenten ulrich von diesen
ulrich woran liegt das denn er ist ganz
simpel welche mathematik über ein
drittel der wahlberechtigten sind über
60 an uns vorbei wird hier keiner
kanzler und wir sind die ersten senioren
generationen die offen sagt wir möchten
dass es unseren kindern mal schlechter
geht
das ist echt sympathisch und ich sagte
ja ich sag das seit jahren vergesst die
doofen erst wähler die eigentliche macht
sind die letzten
deswegen schreiben sich die parteien
auch so ein bei uns jeden tag klingeln
jetzt irgendwelche dödel und kämpfen um
eine stimme mir ist das ehrlich gesagt
manchmal fast schon lästig die merkel
die merkel kommt sogar zweimal die woche
persönlich vorbei und macht mir
schnittchen weil ich ja nicht gemein
viel viel zu wenig getan es ist einfach
nicht ihr ding
aber insgesamt bin ich der grob wo
natürlich dankbar rente mit 63 mütter
rente für meine generation läuft wir
hauen raus was in der kasse ist und ihr
könnt euch für später ja was anderes
überlegen wozu hat gott euch zwei nieren
gegeben einfach mal darüber nachdenken
ja aber ullrich wir verschlafen gerade
die zukunft bei den bildungsausgaben
gehört das reiche deutschland zu den
schlusslichtern europa 8 okon zukunft
wird total überschätzt warum soll dann
der staat bitte in eine zeit investieren
wo ich gar nicht mehr dabei bin und auch
zwei brave kinder mehr kommt so nun
wirklich nicht mehr an
viele ältere publikum heute
durch sehr viele beispiele
ich gebe ihnen anderes beispiel
klimawandel genau dasselbe problem kommt
nicht vor in diesem wahlkampf ja hat zu
recht nicht
können wir bitte einfach mal im jetzt
leben damit ihr in 30 jahren keine
nassen füße kriegt soll ich meinen q7
verkaufen oder einen von meinen porsches
ich denke überhaupt nicht daran wenn er
weg ist dieser wahlkampf läuft optimal
für mich und ich wende mich jetzt direkt
an die parteien freunde ihr habt jetzt
noch genau acht tage meine stimme zu
gewinnen ich erwarte und angebote so und
jetzt muss ich los die junge union trägt
mich jetzt in den saunaclub minuten
[Applaus]